Transcriber: Anjelika Eda Erdem
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
İyi akşamlar!
Tekrardan iyi akşamlar.
Olimpiyat öncesinde okuduğum
ve bazen hayatımda karar vermekte
zorlandığım anlarda danıştığım
bir kitapta, bir söze denk gelmiştim.
’Bir nesnenin değeri, onunla
nereye ulaştığınıza değil,
ona ne ödediğinize ve size kaça
mal olduğuna bağlıdır’ diyor.
Olimpiyat madalyamı elime aldığım zaman
aklıma ilk gelen şeylerden biri de buydu.
Tam on iki yıl.
Tam 12 yıl boyunca bir gün bu madalyaya
kavuşmanın hayaliyle yaşadım.
En başa dönecek olursak, boksla tanışmam,
hatta spora başlamam tamamıyla tesadüf.
Aslında ailem için de çok
güzel bir tesadüf değil.
Yani erkek kardeşim kolunu kırdıktan sonra
çok ağrılı ve sancılı bir dönem geçirdi.
Çok uzun bir dönem fizik tedavi gördü ve
kolunu yüzde yüz anlamıyla kullanamıyordu.
Doktorumuzun anneme sporla birlikte işimiz
daha da kolaylaşır demesiyle,
evimizin yakınlarındaki bir spor salonuna
annem erkek kardeşimi yazdırdı.
Tabii bu süreçte de annem çalıştığı için
yolda başka bir sakatlık olmaması adına
erkek kardeşime ben eşlik ediyordum.
Birkaç hafta salona gidip gelirken
ben sadece ders kitaplarımı
yanımda götürüyorum,
o çalışana kadar onu bekliyorum,
antrenmanı bitince onunla birlikte
eve geri dönüyoruz.
Birkaç hafta sonra, hala on iki yıldır
birlikte çalıştığım antrenörüm bana:
’Sen neden bekliyorsun?
Sen de erkek kardeşinle birlikte çalış,
akşam eve beraber geri dönersiniz’ dedi.
Ben de ‘olabilir aslında’ diyerek
o gün antrenmana başladım.
Birkaç ay sonra annem hem
erkek kardeşimin hem de benim
genel olarak durumumuzu öğrenmek için
antrenörüm ile görüşmeye geldi.
Antrenörüm ilk başta böyle
biraz anneme bakarak:
’İkisi beraber geliyor ama
kız daha yetenekli,
erkeği başka bir branşa mı
yönlendirsek?’ dedi.
Tabi o zamana kadar sporcu
bir aileden gelmediğim için
spor yapan bir aile geçmişim,
ailemin geçmişi sporla bütün
değil, boksu tanımıyoruz.
Türkiye'de erkek sporu olarak
adlandırılıyor.
Ailem için karar alınması
zor bir durum olsa da
onlar benim bir şeyler
başarabileceğime inandığı için
arkamda destek olarak bu spora
başlamama yardımcı oldular.
Tabii ailem, annem, antrenörüm
ile görüşene kadar,
ben antrenmanlarda hem kız hem de erkek
partner bulmakta zorlanıyorum.
Çünkü kimse benimle çalışmak istemiyor.
Benimle çalışan tek kişi erkek kardeşim.
O da akşam beni evde
anneme şikayet ediyor.
‘Ablam bana vuruyor’ diyor.
Annem de bana:
‘Kardeşini neden vuruyorsun?’ diyor.
Sürekli tabi
İşin içinde olduğum için o zamana kadar
bunu algılayamadım ve tabii
yaşım küçük olduğu için.
Antrenörümün böyle bir adım atmasından
sonra annemin de destek olmasıyla,
benim için profesyonel olarak
sporculuk hayatı tam olarak başlamış oldu.
Daha zor antrenmanlar, daha iyi dinlenme,
daha iyi beslenme, daha iyi dinlenme,
özel hayata eskisi kadar
zaman ayıramama gibi.
Ama bunları bir zaman sonra isteyerek,
hayallerimin peşinden koşmak
istediğimi fark ederek,
çok daha istekli bir
şekilde yapmaya başladım.
Ama tabii uzun bir süre başarısızlıkla
geçen bir dönem da var.
Bu dönemde de hepimiz gibi ben de
iki cephede savaşmaya başladım.
Hem dış cephe hem de iç cephe, dış cephe
her zaman daha kolay aslında.
Kiminle yarışacağımı, kime nasıl bir
strateji uygulayabileceğimi biliyordum.
Ama iç cephe hepimiz için daha zor.
Yanınızda gibi görünen,
başarısızlığımızı isteyen
ya da yaptığım sporun bana yakışmadığını
düşünen az da olsa bir kesim.
Bunlarla mücadele etmeye başlarken,
hem de mücadele ederken, aynı zamanda da
başarısız olmam, onlar için biraz daha
konuşma imkanı yarattı diyebilirim.
Ama bir zaman sonra başarmaya ve
madalyaya ulaşmaya başladıkça,
bu kesimi daha çok
mutsuz ettiğimi fark ettim.
Onların konuşması, benim onların
konuşmasından daha çok güç alarak
ivmemi yükseltmem onları mutsuz ve
neden mutlu ediyordu?
Erkek sporu olarak adlandırdıkları  sporda
ya da bana yakışmadığını düşündükleri
eldivenlerimle önce Avrupa Şampiyonu,
sonra Avrupa Oyunları Şampiyonu,
sonra Avrupa’nın en iyi boksörü,
dünya ikincisi
ve şu an olimpiyat gümüş madalya sahibi
bir sporcu olarak karşınızda duruyorum.
Çok zorlu geçen ve yorucu geçen bir
dönemin sonrasında da olimpiyatlarda
yarışabilmek, olimpiyatlarda sahne
alabilmek benim için çok önemliydi.
Olimpiyat final günü işler benim için
yolunda gitmemiş gibi göründü.
Yani en azından o zaman
ben öyle zannediyordum.
Daha sonrasında kendi başıma kaldığımda.
Ben bu zamana kadar hep bir
olimpiyat hayali kuruyorum.
Hep bir olimpiyat altın
madalyası istiyorum.
Ama şimdiki gümüş madalyamla,
iki olimpiyat hayali daha
kurduğumu fark ettim.
Telefonla odada annemle ilk görüştüğümde
çok ağladım, çok üzüldüm.
Annem bana: ’Şu an orada olduğun için
ne iş başardığının farkında değilsin.
Türkiye’ye geldiğinde bunu
anlayacaksınız’ dedi.
Gerçekten de öyle.
Türkiye'ye geldiğimde çok güzel
geri dönüşler aldım.
Çok güzel insanlarla karşılaştım.
Çok güzel düşünceler duydum ama
beni en mutlu eden anlardan biri.
Ben olimpiyattayken mahalledeki bütün
esnafın kendi arasında para toplayıp,
benim kocaman bir pankartımı
yapıp, mahalleye asmalarıydı.
Hepsi benden daha heyecanlı,
olimpiyat madalyamı alıp,
mahalleme geri dönmemi bekliyorlardı.
Ben de artık olimpiyat derken
onların heyecanını gördüğüm için
artık bitsin gideyim,
onlar da rahat etsin,
artık rahat uyusunlar diye
düşünmeye başlamıştım.
Mahalleye geldikten sonra herkes ve
mahalledeki tek tek bütün oturan
küçük, genç, yaşlı herkesle
o pankartın altında fotoğraf çekildim.
Daha sonrasında bir gün
fotoğraf çekimi bitmeye yakın
mahallemizin çok eski esnaflarından biri
’Buse, pankartı yaptıran esnaf, seninle
bir fotoğraf çekilmek istiyor.’ dedi.
Ben de, tabii olur, dedim.
Ya da dedi şöyle mi yapsak sen
madalyanı boynuna taksan,
biz tek tek dükkanları gezsek,
fotoğraf çekilsek.
Dedim ki: ’Abi o artık
belediye başkanlığına giriyor.
Ona şu an değil, daha sonra.′
O olaydan sonra, gerçekten
ne kadar desteklediklerini ve
ne kadar bu duyguya
aç olduklarını hissettim.
Benim için en önemli anlardan biriydi,
gerçekten ömrüm boyunca
unutamayacağım anlardan biri.
Tabi bu kadar başarılı olmadığım
bir süreç daha var.
2018 yılında performansımın belki de
en iyi olduğu dönemlerden birinde
çok iyi hazırlandığımız bir
Dünya Şampiyonası’nda ilk turda elendim.
Siklet sporu yaptığım için
çok zor kilo düşüyorum ve
gerçekten maça yakın bir süre istediğim
kadar, istediğim derecede beslenemiyorum.
O gece odama geri geldim.
Telefonumu kapattım, kendime
bir makarna hazırladım
büyük bir tabakta, ağlayarak o makarnayı
yerken sporu bırakma kararı aldım.
Artık yapamıyorum, artık olmuyor.
Demek ki buraya kadarmış.
İki gün boyunca antrenörümle
hiç konuşmadık.
Günaydın, merhaba, iyi geceler.
Kesinlikle olmadı.
Üçüncü günün akşamı bana ’Yarın
sabah 9’da kahvaltısını yapmış ol.
On birde antrenmanımız var’ dedi.
Sonra durup kendi başıma düşündüğümde
’Ben çok çabuk mu pes ettim?
Bu kadar başarısız bir döneme rağmen
o hala benim için çabalıyor.′ dedim.
Gerçekten de öyleydi.
Tam 8 gün yenildiğim bir turnuvada,
Türkiye’ye dönene kadar her gün
antrenman maçı yaptım.
Belki de orada dünya şampiyonu olsaydım
daha az maç yapıp, daha az yorulurdum.
Gerçekten o süreçten sonra
Türkiye’ye döndüğümde
en büyük başarılarımı o andan
sonra yakalamaya başladım.
Benim için kırılma noktası
tamamiyle orasıydı.
Zemini gördüm diyebilirim.
Zemini gördükten sonra yukarıya çıkmak,
karar verip yukarıya çıkmak
benim için daha kolay oldu.
Daha da güzel oldu.
Her zaman inandığım ve
çok basit olan bir felsefe var.
Siz, diğer insanlar ne kadar başarılıysa,
ben o kadar başarılıyım.
Ben o kadar büyük
bir başarının bir parçasıyım.
Benim Olimpiyat madalyam,
renginden baz alınarak
hepinizin ışığı, hepinizin umudu
olsun diyorum.
Siz ne kadar başarılıysanız ben o kadar
başarılı , biz o kadar başarılıyız.
Herkese çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Hoşça kalın.